[Music]
as the pandemic descended on the world
in 2020 people needed some outlet to get
out of the house to be around friends
maybe even get in some light exercise
while not risking spreading covet
one sport checks all of those boxes
and that is golf and to call it a
resurgence would be an understatement
as we went through 2020 and the world
shut down we went from concerned about
solvency and when we're going to open
and if people are going to be playing
golf to the largest golf boom that i've
ever been a part of according to the
national golf foundation in 2020 there
were 24.8 million golfers in the united
states an increase of about 500 000 and
2 over 2019 the largest net increase in
17 years
golf's popularity right now has only one
comparison in the past
tiger who was amazing but his star
burned very bright and then uh it didn't
have as strong a lasting power but
that's normal for a unique athlete right
they they go through those those phases
as opposed to what we're seeing right
now which is some structural change
along with what is candidly a cova
dividend
but it's more than just the pandemic
that has made golf's popularity
it's also sweeping changes to the game
itself
their cultural aspects of golf that i
would say historically did not make it
friendly i would say i think that is
changing dramatically now it is becoming
inclusive in the sense that everybody is
welcome golf is becoming cooler the
mystique of like what is a golfer is
becoming more and more of a golfer is me
a golfer could be anyone
in addition there are companies and
technologies emerging both on and off
the course that are making the game more
accessible making players better and
diversifying who decides to play the
sport yep good contact there's 80
million golfers in the world of that i
would say probably 50 to 60 million are
looking to get better for anybody who's
looking to get better it's for you and
it created features within there that
help you target it but can this
popularity be sustained for the long
haul that's what i'm about to find out
this is the future of golf
and the question in the minds of
stakeholders around the globe is one of
reinvention and momentum can the age-old
game of golf convert its momentary
success into permanent gains
[Music]
so here's the thing about golf it's hard
it's expensive and it's intimidating and
in a place like new york city it's
really hard to find a real course that
you can actually get access to but there
is one place that's starting to figure
out a couple of those challenges first
the space and second the intimidation
factor and you don't have to worry about
being as terrible as someone like me
you may have seen this pop up on your
tik tok or instagram feeds people taking
videos of themselves here
it's a place called topgolf
[Music]
topgolf is the avenue for
most of the world to
experience golf and get into golf and it
never existed back in the early 2000s
that's chip brewer the ceo of callaway
which bought topgolf in march of 2021.
topgolf is like if a driving range an
arcade and a bowling alley had a baby
and it's the leading off-course golf
experience in the world
[Music]
the encore golf is what you think
traditional golf so there's 24 million
people in the u.s that play golf on a
golf course
per year but most of those play one
round
okay so and then off course golf means
that you experience golf not on a green
grass golf course so that is you're
going to a top golf or a driving range
there are currently 70 top golf
locations around the world today and
it's growing fast with the biggest
topgolf ever slated to open in china
so we don't hand you a rule book we hand
you immediate pathway to fun and having
a good time with people you care about
this is arty stars the ceo of topgolf
artie tell me about your customer
because as they come through topgolf
it's not just folks who look like you
and me so when we look at our venue
business
we think everyone is a potential guest a
potential customer
since traditional golf skus old and
white
topgolf's gamification of the driving
range appeals to a younger more diverse
crowd people who might not otherwise
even think about picking up a club
[Applause]
[Music]
you would see families you would see
different ages you would see different
backgrounds different income brackets
people who have never played golf before
and people who play a lot if you came to
one of our venues you would see that
people with all sorts of backgrounds all
sorts of golf experience non-golf
experience and we have over 70 venues in
the us right now approximately 500 000
guests per venue so 35 million
experiences that we have every year
however there are aspects to topgolf
that appeal to more serious golfers and
that's its technology called top tracer
which gives the customer more
information on the distance height and
speed of their drives
our top tracer business that tends to
cater a bit more to people who are
trying to get better at golf and might
spend you know a couple hours at a
driving range and stay engaged in our
app when i grew up taking golf lessons
it was very much a you know lick your
finger okay make your swing a little bit
better now we give you an app we tell
you how
far and high and fast your ball is going
we give you exercises and actual things
to do we do this at topgolf as well when
it comes to the popularity of topgolf
it's a rising tide that lifts all boats
for both topgolf and callaway i think
for people that are coming in and
playing for the first time or the for
the first time in a while
we are a place that can remind
guests of the thrill of hitting a ball
and having fun with a golf club in your
hand
topgolf is changing the world of golf
and it's creating access to
you know players of all types by merging
the two
we have a competitive advantage in
overall reach to golfers of all
abilities
and you think about growth of the sport
but then growth of our business
one of the biggest reasons people don't
stick to golf is because it's hard
as the famous quote goes golf is a good
walk spoiled but sal syed the ceo of
arcos is out to change that
[Music]
so now we're on like a short par four
okay for the reward that you're looking
for
it's your data guy
analytics you go to business school get
this idea and the idea turns out to be
a golf tech company how why tell me the
story we realized that there was
literally nobody touching data in golf
and data golf's a huge industry like 90
100 billion dollars spent every year on
golf and the entire reason for existence
of a golfer is to get better at golf and
that improvement ends up showing as your
score but that score is composed of so
many different things so many different
shots that are taken how they're taken
and we realized that we need to track
every shot that's been taken on the golf
course to then analyze correctly where
your strengths and weaknesses lie
wind is kind of coming this way eight
miles an hour
an actual is 86 playing like 87 so
that's what we're gonna do
in the most basic terms
how does it work and the way it works is
there's a one-time pairing process so
these sensors think of them as impact
detection sensors so they're detecting
whenever you make impact with a golf
ball when it's paired with your
smartphone so we're basically dropping
pins every shot you take
and we're recording a bunch of
information around it what club was used
what was the terrain was it you started
the t ended up in the left rough how far
the left rough was it what were the
weather conditions what direction was
the wind going was it sunny or not was
it cloudy or not like all those
different things factor in and then
we're able to analyze your game but very
simply we're recording every shot and
then giving you insights about what your
strengths and weaknesses are
[Music]
so use this to to help me understand
how this technology would help me as a
putter this is one of the wildest greens
in golf it has a five foot swale they
got traversed and i have looking at like
a 55 foot putt and for me to get better
at this course i knew i was going to
have enough 50 plus foot putts i need to
improve that part of my game so the app
highlighted you know my zero ten feet is
good i'm draining a lot of those 10 to
25 25 to 50. no problem it's 50 plus
that whenever i'm getting there i was in
trouble so i started practicing lag buds
like look at this but this is like
60 feet it helped me target my putting
practice to the exact area which was my
weakness which is 50 plus feet prior to
that you just knew
i'm three putting a lot or i'm yeah and
exactly right and if you know you're
three putting a lot um it could be
um that you're like you don't know what
range you're three putting from that's
really really important context and so
when we track that we're able to then
take all that data over the course of a
round or five rounds and really show you
that this is not an anomaly this is
really where your issue lies and that's
really really important do you want to
take it or you want me to take it i'm
going to take it yeah let's see
all right you want to go just a hair
left over like a foot left of it this is
like this is the craziest way this is
almost like
miniature golf on steroids right
i don't even know what to do here this
is from like a famous hole in france it
was called the chasm hole in beerus
that's good
go in the cup
there's a way to look at this
interestingly and and i want you to
break this down for me where you look at
it's like well this is really only for
really good golfers like who who who can
understand the data who can sort of take
this in
but then i can make the case this notion
of like actually this is for really
crappy golfers
i mean it's a fair question in fact it
seems like it's for everybody but i want
i want you to help me understand like
who gets what from this yeah we cater to
every type of golfer they'll take your
dispersion patterns into account we'll
take the hazards into account the wind
conditions and tell you for each shot
what your optimal club is what arcos
does is it takes that cognitive bias
away and it's able to for the average
golfer out there really help them
understand how far their clubs go so
give me the numbers here like in terms
of growth and and this is all about data
and ever bigger numbers mean better data
right i mean to date we've recorded 500
million shots like in the future playing
without
arcos or technology like it as a golfer
will be
akin to playing without a putter you'll
literally be leaving strokes on the
table um and so i think this will become
um like a mainstay that's i think that's
the evolution of this this sport in any
sport in any industry honestly
ultimately in order for golf to maintain
its momentum it needs companies like
callaway arcos topgolf and even the pga
itself to continue to emphasize the
importance of including a younger more
diverse demographic to play the game
golf has needed
i dare say for a number of years a
little bit of a reboot or a recasting of
itself literally and figuratively
because
this is a demographic that the
traditional demographic golf is getting
older year by year
do you feel that happening i would say
the racial barriers of golf are
withering away i think the economic
barriers are still there golf as an
industry is realizing that's important
to be inclusive
but we need to
every single year
open it up a little bit more
making the game easier to play making
the rules on green grass simpler and
simpler to understand providing more
forums for for competition we always
think that we are going we are pushing
the envelope forward
in terms of making golf more accessible
because this technology is designed for
beginners as well there are a bunch of
people who when you're starting off it's
a little scary you don't know what club
to hit what to do and so we make it
easier yeah we make it easy and then a
huge win not just for the sport but for
the people that will be accessible
because i do believe it's the greatest
sport
you